[Music]  party be pregnant with her first child  the bow DAC yellow rapper debuted her  adorable growing baby belly during her  performance on Saturday Night Live chick  up in your bed the 25 year old singer  wore a kerb hugging white gown that  blatantly showed off her baby bump  rumours cardies expecting her first  child with fiance rapper offset have  been swirling for months and after her  SNL performance cardi took to Twitter to  officially confirm the exciting news  writing I started winning when the whole  world was doubting on me think imma lose  with my little baby counting on me  in January cardi gushed over the  possibility of the family to see our  fashion book quote my real goal is to  have beautiful kids a beautiful mansion  and do business that makes me money  until the day I die  [Music]  [Applause]